so today we're gonna start a new topic
okay I like new topics I'm not telling
you what it is just yet even though the
astute among you may be able to guess
but you can leave space for any we're
gonna begin by just considering the big
and I really mean read idea Oh
proof proof all kinds of thing
what is proof what does it mean to
something and I mean that very broadly
not just in like the mathematics
classroom what would it mean to prove
something that's proving about evidence
yeah providing evidence evidence for
what evidence from argument you try to
convince someone that something is true
right that's what a proof is about prove
beyond a shadow of a doubt but there's
no way you can reasonably doubt what
this means true or not okay now there's
lots of different kinds of proof
depending on what you're trying to
convince someone is true right and
because the different things work
different ways we have different proofs
for each of them so example we live in a
scientific age right so scientific proof
what is it what's it set out to prove
and how does it work
modern rhetorical question what decide
to print what kind of truth are you
trying to convince someone or if you use
a scientific proof what kind of true
hmm is scientific proof for instance is
it interested in like you know like
relationships between human beings or
things that have happened in the past
not really right what science about
science is that or do we have a
definition from like I don't know you 2
or 3 when you first start learning about
science and then our experiments work
it's about the natural world isn't it
it's about natural phenomena that happen
over and over again and you can observe
them and you can see the patterns right
so therefore if that's what scientific
proof is about how does it actually
function how do you prove something
scientifically you have to you have to
make a situation right you have to be
able to control it and you have to be
able to do it how many times many many
times over and over again so scientific
proof morning
it's about repeated experiments and
observations and then you make a
hypothesis and so okay well actually
you're meant to make the hypothesis
first actually but anyway there you go
there's the idea now I alluded before
the fact that not all kinds of proof are
like this right for instance the exact
opposite of this right its historical
previous historical proof this is about
things that have happened and cannot be
repeated by their nature that's what
makes it history right so being that you
can't prove historical things
scientifically how do you prove things
historically how can you know like you
you weren't there
100 years ago a thousand years ago all
is it but we speak with confidence about
yes this happened this is true this is
history how do we do it fossils evidence
if you tweak you're done sauce but what
do you do with these things you just put
them in an inter hate the men say well
look they go this stuff how does how do
you put that all together in order to
constitute proof when it comes to source
or evidence maybe that's like eyewitness
accounts or records or some like that
what you're looking for is the best
explanation that ties all of these
things whatever we have recorded ties
them together in a causal way are you
looking for relationships right you're
like what will one it happened why did
it happen what's the best explanation
for all of the things that we observe
Franz Ferdinand is an assassination and
all the people who allied themselves
what can what explanation can put all of
this together right and when you come up
with a good one you say well this is
what happened this is our you can
historically prove something now
scientific proof
it started off proof this is not a
science or history classroom though is
it right so even though there's more
kinds the last one I'm interesting than
that of course is mathematical proof now
mathematical proof again just like these
they're all different there's different
methods associated with different truths
that are being handled and argued about
right so if this works by repetition
this works by putting together evidence
in a causal way think about it you've
been improving things for years you know
a lot about mathematical proof what
kinds of pieces you know experiments the
piece to evidence one of the pieces that
make a mathematical proof
how do bro statements this this
compositions right propositions that's
important proper positions
I can spell to wear it sorry guys
propositions you put them together
rather than with I think this cause that
right we put them together with logic
right and then you form an argument just
like you would with any of these okay
but right mathematical proof even though
I'm kind of presenting is like equal um
you know one among equals it's actually
very very different from the rest okay
because mathematical proof is the only
kind of proof not just this list of any
kind of proof you can think of right
which is irrefutable mathematical proof
is the only kind of proof that is
irrefutable what's that mean what does
it mean to refute something in a debate
there's there's refuting right which is
to say no they're wrong it is first
speak up what a judge right that's
that's for few things right but not the
medical proof if you prove something
mathematically it can never ever without
a shadow if you really did prove it it
can't be refuted because there have been
false there are many folks out there for
different things but if a real proof if
they're mathematically you can't refute
them whereas you can scientifically
prove something and it can be according
to the scientific method or historically
you know all the best pieces of evidence
and arguments and all that kind of thing
but well scientists you should get over
to all the time how you make a new
discovery you find you find new evidence
you like all this blows everything out
of the water right we never did land on
the moon
oh no or whatever kind of conspiracy
theory right but it doesn't matter how
much a new mathematical stuff you
discover if you discover something
that's mathematically true in you prove
it it's always true the example you can
take any whole number any whole number
and you can write it as the sum of four
squares did you know that
any whole number you like Foursquare
phosphate integers okay think of one
give me a number just stop asking for
numbers okay I make up my own one
come on let's divide it up we can divide
it into four squares or less but you
just make it zero squared which is how
you do it
what were you saying what's the biggest
square you can fit in it come on twelve
surely okay hundred forty-four all right
so that would be three
wouldn't it it's a big square you can
fit in that one isn't it you do it three
times so you go three minus one squared
is 2 2 minus 1 squared is 1 1 minus 1
squared you get to zebra so 147 is 1
squared plus 1 squared plus 1 squared
plus 4 squared
cows before you know how about 10 what's
the biggest we can feed him in 14 what's
that 196 so that would leave you with 14
wouldn't it right yeah
what's the biggest way you can fit that
3 that's 9 should leave you with 5 you
think that twos that's one 210 is 1
square plus 2 square plus 8 plus 14
squared we could keep playing this game
for a while if you liked it's improving
this is uncalled Lagrange is 4 square
theorem for obvious reasons okay it's
always going to be true there's nothing
new that can ever be discovered that
will disprove this thing's ok that's
interesting it's pretty freaking awesome
right mathematical proof is unique in
that way